when the government prints that amount
of money
effectively what they're doing is is
devaluing the currency and when they
give it to rich people effect what
they're doing is massively increasing
inequality right so then you see this
situation where the rich make an
enormous amount of money the fastest
ever increase in millionaire billionaire
wealth ever in the country and ordinary
people
can't afford to pay the bills right and
all the prices go up you know let's
let's be clear inflation is
coming up to 10 percent now
and you know most of the people watching
will not have received 10 increases
in their pay you know
i think most people would be lucky if
they're getting three or four percent
that means in real terms
people's pays fall in six percent seven
percent
at the same time as the billionaires
have never ever ever made more money so
it should
in my opinion never in the history of
economics has it been more obvious what
needs to be done you know the government
gave a ton of money to rich people that
is destroying the lives of poor and
ordinary people you need to take the
money